ALEXANDRA PELOSI: Mom,
why did you choose this life?
NANCY PELOSI: I didn't really
choose this life.
It chose me.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
ALEXANDRA: I put the picture
of me and you there,
so that all my siblings
can see I'm your favorite.
For my entire adult life,
I have been two steps behind you
with this camera,
trying to keep up with you.
NANCY: I am a work horse,
not a show horse.
I was born into a family
that was fiercely patriotic
and staunchly democratic.
Politics was the life
that we led.
I have the high privilege
as the first president
to begin the State of the Union
message with these words:
Madam Speaker.
(CHEERING, APPLAUSE)
NANCY: We're there to do a job.
(DENOUNCING CHATTER)
NANCY: Not to keep a job.
And we're gonna fire Pelosi!
NANCY: Some people count sheep
at night, I count votes.
I cannot take a bill
to the floor with this in it.
This is, you know,
a backdoor way
for something that I said
we could not cross
the threshold of.
Here's what happens
in negotiations.
You can't get tired.
You can never get tired.
-ALEXANDRA: Are you gonna be
on your best behavior tonight?
-NANCY: Yes, I am.
ALEXANDRA:
Don't do anything I wouldn't do.
Thank you very much.
REPORTER:
Why did you tear it up?
It was a total pack of lies.
Let us pray that today,
January 6th,
will be an epiphany
for the American people.
ALEXANDRA:
Look at the protestors
outside the Capitol.
SPEAKER: Oh, my God!
How did that guy get up there?
NANCY:
SPEAKER 2:
Mr. Vice President,
don't let anybody know
where you are.
We always knew that
this responsibility
would take us into the night.
We'll stay as long as it takes.
When I call the House to order,
I hope that it stays in order.
If it doesn't stay in order,
I'll call it to order again.
(LAUGHTER)
ALEXANDRA:
You're always on message.
There's no cracking you, huh?
Well, um,
that's what you want to do,
crack your mom.
(LAUGHS)
ALEXANDRA: Yes, I do.
I want to crack you.
(LAUGHS)